REAGAN SIGGARD: Hi,
DATA 2100 students.
In this in-class
assignment, we're
going to learn what we have
applied this week in for loops
and combining our knowledge
of SQL and Python.
So we've talked about lists
and for loops this week,
and then we talked
about how do we
write an SQL SELECT
statement in Python
and then have that output
to us in our Python program?
So we're going to go through
our in-class assignment today.
If you have not already watched
all the videos of this week,
please make sure to do so.
In this in-class
assignment, we're
going to click Copy to Drive.
And then, you'll notice that
mine now-- that is gone.
That prompt is gone once
I've copied it to Drive.
And then, I'll type in
my first and last name.
All right, we're ready to go.
Here, you're going to turn
in two different files--
the PDF and the
Jupyter Notebook file.
So make sure that you do that.
All right, so here,
using Python and SQL,
for each of the problems
below, you will need to know--
and we've already
talked about this.
But we are accessing our
database via a database file.
So previously, when we
were writing SQL queries,
we were accessing
the database as it
was being stored on our server,
our Microsoft SQL Server.
For feasibility,
we have actually
downloaded that
database into a file.
But it still behaves the same
as the database on the server.
However, it's just much easier
to access within Google Colab.
But this is still extremely
applicable in industry
because the only thing
that will change,
as far as if you
were to be accessing
a server, say, on Amazon Web
server or somewhere else,
then you just change
this connection code,
and everything else is the same.
So it's good that way.
So you'll notice
you'll be prompted
to download the
overland_sqlite database file
as well to make sure that you
can go through this with me.
And should just note here that
the database file will only
persist while your Colab
Notebook session remains active.
So if it sits for some
time, if you sign out,
you're going to need to
reupload the database file.
But we'll get to that in
just a [? question. ?]
That's not till program 3.
But here in programs
1 and 2, we're
going to practice our for
loops as well as our lists.
And we're going to create a
variable called favemovie.
And then we're going to set
the value of this variable
to be your favorite
movie, then ask the user
to guess your favorite movie,
then append the movie they
guessed to a list.
All right, let's go
ahead and do this here.
So I don't know if I've
told this online class.
I probably have.
But I am not at
all a movie person.
I'm not against them.
I just never really
watch movies.
So when I'm asked
my favorite movie,
I'm like, um,
[LAUGHS] I don't know.
I don't actually
know if I've ever
seen Cinderella or anything.
I don't think I've
seen Cars, but we're
going to say Cars is
my favorite movie.
It's not, but we're
going to say that.
So set your favorite movie here.
And I know, it's weird.
I need to, I guess, watch
more movies, but here we are.
So then I want to ask the user
to guess my favorite movie,
then append the movie
they guessed to a list.
So I first need to
ask my user to guess.
So I'll make a comment here.
# #ask user to guess
my favorite movie.
And I'll say, userguess equal to
Input("Please guess my favorite
movie").
So I'm going to ask that.
Because users input it as a
string, that's totally fine.
That's what we want it as.
# And then, I want to
#create an empty list
so that I can actually append
the values to that list.
So I'm going to say,
userguesslist equal to empty.
[LAUGHS] And I'm actually
going to maybe move this up,
if you will.
I like to declare all of my
variables and things up front.
So I'm going to go ahead and
move that userguesslist up.
And then what I'm going to
do after I ask for my user
to guess, I'm going to say, you
know what, userguesslist.append.
And I'm going to, again,
use that append() method,
and I'm going to place the value
from the variable userguess
into the userguesslist.
So again, I'm
appending this value
that my user guesses
to my userguesslist.
So let's go ahead and run this.
It's going to take
a second here.
It says, "Please guess
my favorite movie."
If I say, let's see,
sandlot, and I hit Enter,
then all I know is that
it appends to a list,
and that's it.
So maybe I could say,
print(userguesslist).
Now, when I run it again,
and I guess Sandlot again,
then the only thing that's going
to return to me is sandlot.
So just keep in mind here this
is a fairly simple program.
We're just asking the
user to guess something.
Then, we are going to add the
value that they guess to a list,
and then we're
printing out that list.
All right, now, same as
above, but if the user guesses
your favorite movie, then
congratulate them and tell them
how many times they guessed.
Also, output to
the user once they
guess the correct movie all of
the names of the movies they
guessed.
If the user does not
guess your favorite movie,
encourage them to try again.
Continue until the user
guesses your favorite movie.
Be sure this program
is not case-sensitive.
So I'm going to come up here.
I'm going to grab my
program from up above.
I'm going to paste it down here.
And I'm going to still have my
favorite movie declared up here.
I'm going to still
create my userguesslist.
And then, down here, after
I've appended my userguess,
I am going to then evaluate.
Did what they enter--
is it actually my
favorite movie?
So I'll say, if the userguess
is not equal to favemovie,
then I want to print "You did
not guess my favorite movie--"
and then I want to tell them
how many times they've guessed--
"You have guessed blank times."
I'm going to add in my counter
variable here sometime.
As a reminder, the best
thing to do with while loops
is add them at the very
end of your program.
While loops will
make your program
happen over and
over and over again,
and that can cause issues.
If you're stuck in
this infinite loop that
just keeps running and running
and running and running,
that's going to be an issue.
So I prefer to get my base
program working, meaning
my variables created my
inputs, and my program
that I want to happen
over and over again,
I want that to exist before
I put in my while loop.
So I'm going to use
eventually a counter variable
to guess the number of times.
But for right now, I'm just
going to say "blank times."
And then I'll add in
here in just a bit,
once I add in my while
loop, my counter variable.
All right, so then, ELSE means--
# else, #they did guess
my favorite movie.
And once they do guess
my favorite movie,
I want to output to them
everything that they guessed.
So let me first tell
them-- print("Great job!
You guessed my favorite movie!
It took you blank times.").
So again, I'm going to have a
counter variable eventually when
I add in my while loop.
But for now, I'm just
going to say "blank,"
and then I'll come
and fill that in.
All right, so once they have
guessed my favorite movie--
so if this IF()
evaluates as true,
meaning they did not
guess my favorite movie,
then this PRINT
statement will run.
If this evaluates as false,
then my ELSE will run.
Now, what I want to do
is I want to now loop
through my
userguesslist and output
to them the movies
that they have guessed.
So let's run what
we have right now
and just make sure
this logic's working.
Run our code often.
So what if I say "cinderella"?
I hit Enter.
"You did not guess
my favorite movie.
You have guessed blank times."
OK, that's perfect.
"cars."
The ELSE should run when they
do guess my favorite movie.
And it says, "Great job!
You guessed my favorite movie!
It took you blank times."
OK, perfect.
Now, this next time, I
actually want to output
to them their guesses.
So I'm going to say,
for x in userguesslist.
So now, this is a list, and I'm
going to loop through this list.
I want to print(x).
So now, I run it, and I say
"cinderella," for example.
It says, "You did not
guess my favorite movie.
You have guessed blank times."
Perfect.
When I type in "cars,"
then it says, "Great job!
You guessed my favorite movie!
It took you blank times."
And then I'm printing
to them "cars."
Maybe up here, when I am
printing to them "It took you
blank times," I'm going to
say, "You guessed--" and then,
that way, when my
for loop runs again,
it'll look a little better.
It says, "Great job!
You guessed my favorite movie!
It took you blank times.
You guessed," colon,
and then "cars."
So once I add in my while loop,
and this append() is run more
than once, then I will get
more than one guess appended
to my list, and it
will output more to me.
So now, I also want to add
in here a counter variable.
counter = 0.
In this counter variable, I want
to increase by one every time
I ask for user's input.
So now, I'm going
to run this again.
"Please guess my
favorite movie."
I'd say "cinderella."
I hit Enter.
"You did not guess
my favorite movie.
You have guessed blank times."
Oh, I need to come here
in this "blank times."
I want to change this and
have it actually be "(counter)
times."
Same thing here,
"(counter) times."
OK, awesome.
Now, let's run it.
"Please guess my
favorite movie."
I say "cinderella," hit Enter.
It says, "You did not
guess my favorite movie.
You have guessed 1
times," which is great.
That's what it's supposed to do.
Now, at this point, I want
to continue asking them
because we notice here,
every time I answer, I
have to rerun the program.
So I want to continue making
this happen over and over
and over again.
So I'm going to
use a while loop.
And I'm going to say--
well, I'm going to
use a marker variable.
Well, actually, I'll say--
the marker variable
can be anything.
So I'm going to say,
y is equal to 0.
And this is my marker variable.
Now, this is
something that you're
going to be tested on as well.
But a marker
variable, its purpose
is to start the while loop
and then exit the while loop.
So I'm going to say, while
the marker variable is equal,
equal to 0, continue
doing this over and over
and over again until you
break out of the loop.
And I want to leave
the loop once they've
guessed my favorite movie and
once I've output to them what
they guessed to me.
So a marker variable, when I
run this, if I say "cinderella,"
and I hit Enter, this
should return to me--
"You did not guess
my favorite movie.
You have guessed 1 times."
OK, great.
Let's say "sandlot."
So I'm still guessing
the incorrect movie.
I've guessed two
times at this point.
And now I finally say
"cars," it says, "Great job!
You guessed my favorite movie!"
So my ELSE block ran everything
indented and beneath it.
"It took you 3 times."
And then, "You guessed--" and my
for loop runs because it's also
indented beneath the ELSE block.
And then I finally leave the
loop, and my program ends.
Now, a good question for
this would be, well, now,
what if I actually had my
marker variable equal to one,
something different than up
here, what I established it as?
What would happen?
And the answer is nothing
runs in my program
because this while loop never
runs because y is equal to zero.
So this is not true.
So the while loop
will never run.
So if I have it like this,
then the while loop never runs,
and my program just
ends, and that's it.
All right, so I
want to make sure
that that marker variable
is equal to whatever
I've established it
for to start that loop.
And then, again, we can
try a few other things.
But that is good to go.
OK, perfect.
Now, finally, here, we're
going to get into our SQL.
I think we did it all.
Yeah.
Oh!
Be sure this program
is not case-sensitive.
So up here, right now, if I was
to type in-- let's come back up
here--
"Cars" with a capital C, it says
that I did not guess my favorite
movie.
And I'm like, but why?
Well, the reason is because
I have established that
my favorite movie is equal
to "cars," all undercase.
So when I run this, and I
input "Cars" with an uppercase,
then it says, oh,
yeah, this is true
because it's case-sensitive.
So what I want to do is I want
to come here and use my .lower()
method to lower my userguess
to be all lowercase.
So now, when I enter, even if
I enter something with capital
"Cars," and I hit Enter,
it will still run.
And it still
recognizes that, oh,
that's the correct guess
because I've used .lower().
So just keep that in mind.
Now, down here on
program 3, we're
going to connect to
the Overland database,
and we're going to
run a query that
outputs the first and last
name, age, season pass
status of all guests
who have a season pass
and are between the
ages of 30 and 35.
I'll say "season pass."
There we go.
Have a season pass--
all right, apologies
about that--
and are between the
ages of 30 and 35.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to come up here.
I'm going to copy this
code from up above
and paste it down here
into Program 3 code.
And what I'm going to
say is that once I--
you'll notice that it's just
going to run my overland_sqlite.
So I'm going to make sure
that we upload that file.
So let's just make sure that
we upload this file here
before we run that again.
So make sure you upload
the file and make
sure you've downloaded it.
So I'm going to click
overland_sqlite.
And you'll notice here that
it gives that warning that
if you sit here with the
Python program too long,
then you're going to
notice that it times out.
And you need to upload
that file again.
So I had previously
had that file in here,
but I am just going
to reupload that.
And we're good to go.
So now that I have
this file-- it's
basically my storage of
all my files over here
that I'm using to access
in this Colab notebook.
So you could add in all
sorts of other data over here
and just connect to it.
So once I've done that, and
I'm connecting to that database
file, then I want to
come down here and create
what we call a cursor.
And a cursor is basically--
it's an object in Python that
will go and run this SQL query
that we tell it to go run.
And then it brings back the
data for us from that database.
So I'm going to tell the cursor
to go ahead and run this query.
So I'm going to give
it a query to run.
I'm going to say, you know what,
SELECT first name, last name,
Age, and SeasonPass.
Remember, all this comes
from my Guest table.
OK, so we want to
check that out.
My Guest table contains the
first name, last name, age,
and season pass status
of all of my guests.
So we're back here
to our database.
We're going to make
sure that we're
pointing to that right table.
So I'm going to say,
FROM the Guest table
WHERE Age BETWEEN 30 AND 35
AND SeasonPass equal to yes.
So that's the query that
I want to have it run.
Now, what you'll notice
is I'm going to play this,
and it gives me where
the cursor is located.
So basically, it's saying,
all right, Reagan, we went,
we've run the query.
Now, what is my
responsibility is
to now pull that
data that's basically
sitting in that cursor,
if you will, into a list.
So just like what
we did up above,
and we've talked about
this in our videos,
we're going to pull this
into a list called results.
And we're going to say,
results = cursor.fetchall().
What this fetchall() means
is pull all of those records
of data returned to you, fetch
all of them from the cursor,
and place it in the
results variable as a list.
Then what I can do is I can
come here, and I can say,
you know what,
for x in results--
or actually, let's just
say print(results) for now.
OK, so let's go
ahead and run this.
And what you'll
notice is returned
to me is this is all on a list.
This results is a list.
And every value in
this list is a tuple,
which we've talked about.
The tuple is similar to a list.
It's just not changeable.
But basically, what this is
is this is a database record--
Jaelynn, Stephens, age 31,
does have a season pass.
So Jaelynn is a
guest in my database.
This is all of
Jaelynn's information
that is returned to me
based upon this query.
So this is like a horizontal
record that's output to me,
just like it would
be in Beekeeper.
So if I was to run
this-- let's just
pull up Beekeeper here quick.
And I'm going to run
the same query there.
And I do not need connection.
Let me just grab this here
really quick and press Connect.
Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo.
And I run this.
Oh, now it's mad at me.
Hold on.
Make sure I'm in my
Overland database.
OK.
So we'll notice here's
Jaelynn Stephens; age, 31;
season pass, yes.
So this is all a tuple.
This is a record of
my database that's
being returned to me here.
So Jaelynn, Stephens, age 31,
yes-- this is a database record.
And I can work with
those database record.
All right, so now that
we figured this out,
what I want to do is instead
of printing it just like this,
just like in this
weird list format,
I actually want to
come up here, and I'm
going to say, for y in results.
And I want to print
these different values.
So I'm going to
use f-strings here.
And I'm going to say I want
to print the first name,
so I'm going to label this data.
Then I'm going to
print the last name.
OK, I'll fill in this
data here in a second.
Then, I'm going
to print the age.
Then, I'm going to print
the season pass status.
And the way that I'm
going to do this is I'm
going to use what we've already
learned so far in the class,
which are index values.
And I know that the
0 index position
is the one that we start with.
So the 0 index position of this
tuple, its value is Jaelynn.
It's the first name.
Remember, Python
starts counting at 0.
So the 0 index value is Jaelynn.
The Stephens is the
second index value.
31 is the third index value.
And the fourth or the-- sorry.
[CACKLES]
Jaelynn's index value is 0.
Stephen's index value is 1.
31's index value is 2.
And then the season pass'--
this y-- index value is 3.
So when I come up here,
I can say, you know what,
bring the value,
again, here within y.
So again, remember, because
when we loop through,
this tuple is assigned to be
the value of y one time through.
And then it prints out
"Jaelynn," "Stephens," "31,"
"y," and then it's going to
print out "Chase" and "Morales."
So let's go ahead, and we're
going to say, you know what,
print y.
And then we're going to pull
the 0 index value, which
would be Jaelynn here.
Then we're going to
print y, and we're
going to say-- oh, that's
not the way I want to do it.
Nope, we're going to say the
variable is y with the 0 index
value.
There we go.
And then, the variable is
y with the 1 index value.
And then, the age
variable, our age is 1--
or sorry, 2.
And then season pass is 3.
OK, so now, when
I run this, we'll
notice here that we get
all of this output to me.
So I get "Firstname--
Jaelynn Lastname--
Stephens Age--
31 SeasonPass-- y.
So I am pulling the data that
we have returned from this SQL
query into this list.
Then, from there,
each of that list
contains a series of tuples.
And each of those tuples, I can
refer to an individual value
within those tuples
using index positions,
and I can print out this nicely
labeled data set here for us.
OK, awesome.
Now, I'm going to again connect
to the Overland database.
I'm going to ask the user
for their first and last name
duh, duh, duh.
Look up the user in the database
based on first and last names.
Assume they are in our database.
If they are in our
database, thank them
for being a valued member
of our Overland community.
Output to them the
information we have about them
in the database.
So I'm going to come up here.
Actually, I'm going to
copy these lines of code,
so from the import--
again, this import
imports these capabilities
of this sqlite3 library.
And these capabilities
are the fact
that I can go and
run this SQL query,
and that's based upon the
fact that I can also create
cursors and things like that.
So now, I come down
here, and I have this.
I want to ask the user for
their first and last name.
And then I'll run a query.
So I'm just basically using
this as a template, that program
I just copied from up above.
Basically, it's
a Lookup program.
I'm looking up the
individuals in my database.
So I'm going to say,
print("Welcome to Overland Ski
Resort.") And then I'm going
to ask them userfirstname.
I'm going to ask them to input--
"Please enter your first name."
Then, I want to ask
them userlastname, say,
input("Please enter
your last name").
So I'm going to ask them for
their first and last name.
And then I'm going to assume
they're in my database.
And then I'm going to output
to them their information.
So let's come down here.
So after I've asked
for their username
and their first and
last name, then I
want to amend my cursor here.
And I want to go
into the database
and enter their first and last
name into my WHERE clause.
So if I was to write this here
in SQL and Beekeeper-- oh,
sorry.
Why-- let's see.
There-- no.
That's not wanting to show.
Hold on.
Oh, it's down here.
[LAUGHS]
So I would say, WHERE first name
equal to-- let's just say if we
were looking for me--
'Reagan' AND last name
equal to 'Siggard.'
Let's just say this is
what I was looking for.
So you will notice I have to
include these straight quotes
around 'Reagan' and 'Siggard."
And so I run this, and there
is nothing output to me
because I'm not in the database.
So let's come up here to the
program that I wrote before.
An Ella Foster, I know,
is in my database,
so let's instead write
'Ella,' 'Foster.'
So I'm just getting the format
here of this database program.
And I'm going to press Run.
And here I have that
Ella Foster is aged 33,
and their season pass is one.
So perfect.
Now, I'm just going to
keep the information--
says, if they are
in our database,
thank them for being a
valued member of our Overland
community.
Output to them the
information we have about them
in the database.
I'm just going to
output them for right
now their first name, last name,
age, and season pass status.
That will be just fine.
So here in my WHERE
clause, I'm going
to use a value from the
variables userfirstname
and userlastname
just like I would
here, where I actually
put in the user's
first name and last
name, like Ella Foster.
So I'll come over here, and
I'll say, WHERE userfirstname--
oh, no, no.
[CHUCKLES]
WHERE first name equal to--
and then, within the single
straight marks, I have to put--
again, I have to use those
because this is going and being
ran as an SQL query.
And we know from
our prior experience
and just from the
program we just wrote,
they have to be within these
marks in order for my SQL query
to run and recognize
them as string data.
So WHERE firstname
equal to userfirstname
and lastname equal to the value
from the variable userlastname.
And again, I have
to use those so
that Python will
recognize it, as those are
these little straight marks.
So now, when I run this,
I'm going to come up here.
I'm going to grab actually
from up above this cursor.
I'm going to grab that code.
This time, instead
of using results,
I'm going to say
outputresults just
to make the variable
name a little bit
different from the
one that I used prior.
OK, so now, when I run this,
I'm going to use Ella Foster.
I would recommend using
somebody as a test case.
So I am to assume they
are in my database.
So I'm going to say "ella,"
and then I'll say "foster"
is my last name.
And I hit Enter, but
nothing returns to me.
Hmm, that's weird.
All right, let's
take a look here.
And last name = userlastname.
userfirstname, userlastname.
outputresults.
[LIP BURBLING]
Let's just see if
there's something here.
What if I just
print(outputresults)?
You're probably seeing it.
You're probably like,
Reagan, this is the issue.
Hold on.
Let me run this again.
I'm going to say "ella"
and then "foster."
And I hit Enter.
OK, so my program runs, and
I just have this empty list.
So nothing is returning to me.
Oh, dear, now I know
what's going on.
I forgot to use f-strings up
here within my cursor.execute().
So it's actually
looking for somebody
with this as their first name
and that as their last name.
All right, now, we
need to use f-string.
So it says, I'll pull the data
from the variable userfirstname
and place it here.
All right, let's run this again.
Let's say "ella," enter,
"foster," hit Enter.
Sweet.
And there's Ella's information.
Now, this one, I'm assuming
that they are in our database.
Oh, I'm going to output to
them, for y in outputresults,
"Thank you for being a part
of our overland community."
And then I'll just return
them first name and last name.
Let's try this again.
"ella," "foster," and I hit
Enter, and it returns them.
Now, what if I was to put
"Reagan Siggard" here?
I'm not in the database.
Nothing outputs to me because
This query did not
return anything to me.
So we're going to address
that down here in program 5.
This time, same
thing, but we're going
to verify that they
are in our database.
So I'm going to copy
down this program,
and paste it here in program 5.
And in this program 5, I am
going to add a few things in.
So I just want to verify
they're in my database.
So one way that I can verify
that they're in my database
is I know that if I run this,
and nothing returns to me,
that the outputresults is empty.
There is nothing in this
outputresults list because, like
we just saw above, if I was to
print(outputresults) and, again,
just run this again, I
say "reagan," "siggard,"
then what returns to
me is this empty list.
So there's nothing in it.
So what I can do is I can
actually say, you know what,
I'm going to use my len()
function that finds out how many
characters is in a string.
I can actually do the
same thing with list.
And I can use that
len() function.
I can say, count the number
of values in this list.
So I will then say, if the
length of outputresults is
# equal, equal to 0, meaning
#the list is empty,
nothing returned to
me, if that is true,
then I just want
to print("Shoot!
You are not in our database.")
Now, if this is not true,
then I want to run ELSE.
And then I want to output
to them this for loop.
So if they are in our
database, do this.
So now, we can go
ahead and run this.
And I'm going to
say ella foster,
I know, is in my database.
Perfect.
This evaluated as
false because there
is one record returned
in my outputresults,
so it's not empty.
And then my ELSE block ran, and
it output their information.
I'm going to run this again.
And I'm going to say
"reagan," "siggard."
The length of my
outputresults will be zero.
So my IF block is true.
And it says, "Shoot!
You are not in our database."
So that's what you have.
That's how we can verify that
they are in our database.
And then, this way, we
can inform them, ooh,
you're not in our database.
But if they are, we can return
to them in their output, still.
Now, make sure you add
in a couple of comments
# here, like #running
the query, #grabbing
all the output
(database records)
and adding it to a
list, and so forth, just
to make good comments
throughout and to help you.
So that's what you have here
for this in-class assignment.
Thanks so much for
your hard work.
Again, get this turned in.
And you're going to turn in
those two different files.
All right, take care, everybody.
Thank you.